[Applaus]
[Musik]
die verbreitung von fekters bolt der
kampf dagegen erklimmen von jahr zu jahr
immer steilere eskalationsstufen auf der
einen seite stehen
verschwörungstheoretiker radikale
ideologen und skrupellose manipulateure
welche die öffentlichkeit in die irre
führen und des informieren wollen aus
eigener verblendung oder um profit
heraus zu stark auf der anderen seite
stehen regierungen seriöse medien und
wohltätige infos welche die bürger vor
diesen unwahrheiten und verführungen
ohne hintergedanken und eigennutz aber
mit geballter macht schützen möchten
koste es was es wolle
wer in deutschland wurde dazu ein gesetz
eingebracht hast den lupenreinen
demokratisch klingenden namen netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz trägt und so
fragwürdig sich dieses gesetz anhört so
hitzig wird auch die kontroverse darüber
geführt was wichtiger ist schutz vor
desinformation oder das grundrecht auf
meinungs und informationsfreiheit wer
soll bestimmen was noch wahrheit ist und
wann die lüge an senkt die justiz oder
immer mehr eine in moralischer
selbstherrlichkeit schwelgende exekutive
ein ministerium für wahrheit welches
diese aufgaben dann sogar an externe
privatfirmen und andy outsourced
oder private netzwerke und plattformen
welche im wahn von über ängstlichkeit
und vorauseilenden gehorsam alles
zensieren was nicht dem mainstream und
der regierungs meinung gestrickt und wer
kontrolliert diese wahrheit' richter und
sensoren sind demokratische
gewaltentrennung und freie
meinungsbildung in einer solchen
verzerrten gesellschaft überhaupt noch
gewährleistet wie weit darf der staat
gehen und wie schützt den bürger vor
einem missbrauch der zensurmaßnahmen
selbst auch die korona krise hat diese
debatte erneut angeheizt alle möglichen
medien youtube kanäle und sozialen
netzwerke was mit wilden spekulationen
und lebensgefährlichen bull um sich und
ja so schwachsinnig dies auch klingen
mag leider haben leute diese ratschläge
befolgt und sind deswegen gestorben das
alles hat die eskalationsspirale rund um
fake news und den kampf von der
regierungs organisationen und sozialen
netzwerken dagegen sich immer schneller
drehen
wie geht facebook mit fake news um die
durch externe faktencheck geprüft werden
alle versuchen das problem irgendwie
anzugehen viele youtuber fordern sogar
selbst youtube aktiv auf entschieden
gegen andere kanäle vorzugehen weil sie
behaupten sie würden hoaxes verbreiten
tja und dann kommt diese eine geschichte
und bringt uns alle dazu alles was wir
über die wahrheit gedacht haben erneut
zu überdenken
wie sich bei akt vom liebling der
analysten zu einem 2,2 milliarden dollar
schweren bilanzskandal entwickelte
ich weiß was du jetzt denkst was hat ein
finanzskandal mit fake news zu tun
nun glaubt mir eine ganze menge wir
sprechen über einen der größten
finanzskandale der deutschen geschichte
ein betrug im umfang von über 1,9
milliarden euro der sich vor den augen
der deutschen aufsichtsbehörden
abspielte und diese waren nicht nur
vollkommen unfähig und unwillig ihn zu
erkennen nein sie hatten sogar nichts
besseres zu tun als diejenigen welche
auf den betrug als erste hingewiesen
haben der verbreitung von fake news zu
bezichtigen munter zu machen und sogar
vor gericht zu zerren
ja das muss man sich mal auf der zunge
zergehen lassen um den hinweisen auf den
betrug bei wirecard nachzugehen
beauftragten die deutschen behörden nur
einen kleinen externen ein mann
dienstleister und prüften dessen arbeit
noch nicht mal
stattdessen konzentrierten sie ihre vom
pfad erarbeiteten geld der steuerzahler
bezahlten ressourcen auf die verfolgung
der legitimen kritiker und wissen
blogger dieses verhalten der deutschen
aufsichtsbehörden und kontrolleure ist
umso verwerflicher als dass es sich bei
wirecard um eine der grössten
zahlungsdienstleister der welt handelte
und geldverkehr ist eine sache bei der
die absolute vertrauenswürdigkeit des
dienstleisters eben durch diese behörden
und prüfe gewährleistet sein sollte
vor allem bei einem so großen
unternehmen wie bayer kam ich bin sicher
dass auch du eine von wirecard diensten
irgendwann mal in anspruch genommen hast
jedes mal wenn du etwas im internet ein
flugticket oder auch bei aldi gekauft
hast starten die chancen gut dass die
transaktion über die technologie sorgen
war ja gerade abgewickelt wurde mit
sicherheit aber falls du mal geld in
einem online casino oder für port
verbraten hast denn genau in diesen
speziellen nischen lagen die anfänge von
bayer kauft
hier war die firma ein platzhirsch und
wie es scheint verfolgt die firmenkultur
wirecard der hauch des halbseidenen und
zwielichtigen bis zuletzt trotz all
ihrer immensen bemühungen und
erfolgsstorys in vielen anderen durch
und durch seriösen branchen und ja ich
weiß dass viele von euch jetzt denken
online zahlungsverkehr das ist auch in
zeiten von krone ein bombengeschäft das
business von wirecard muss doch abgehen
die nachbar stv und tatsächlich wenn es
eine branche gibt die in ungeheuren maß
von der krise profitiert hat dann ist
dies der online handel und auf alles was
mit diele zusammenhängt in einer zeit in
der wir alle dinge online gekauft haben
sind online zahlungsdienstleister stark
gewachsen
da müsste es war doch blenden gehen oder
nun nichts könnte von der wahrheit
weiter entfernt sein als das feuer krad
stürzte in die insolvenz
fünfundzwanzigster juni 2020
ja das hast du vollkommen richtig gehört
denn das einzige womit wirecard in den
letzten monaten schlagzeilen gemacht hat
ist der finanzskandal des jahres so wie
es aussieht hat das unternehmen die
hälfte seines geschäfts einfach frei
erfunden wir sprechen von einem
unternehmen das noch vorletztes jahr 24
milliarden euro wert war und leider ist
die 24 milliarden sind vernichtet nach
der ad hoc mitteilung von sonntagnacht
also drei uhr früh muss man ja
eigentlich sagen hatten wir gleich noch
in der früh ebenfalls einen haftbefehl
beantragt und auch erhalten bekommen und
am gleichen tag hat sich daneben
der ehemalige vorstandsvorsitzende bei
uns gestellt also der haftbefehl lautet
jetzt eben auf unrichtigen angaben und
marktmanipulationen ist es nicht
ausgeschlossen dass wir im zuge unserer
ermittlungen auch noch weitere
straftatbestände zu prüfen haben werden
also wir wissen zum beispiel noch nicht
ob unrichtige bilanzen dann auch dazu
benutzt wurden zu vergleich vielleicht
hättest du dich noch an die großen
deutschen betrüger aus dem hessischen
und bayerischen doktor jürgen schneider
und low tech schmiede deren betrügereien
richteten einen schaden von heute
umgerechnet 3,9 bzw 3,3 milliarden
euro an allerdings waren die
geschädigten damals fast nur banken
nicht wie im fall wirecard eine riesige
zahl von kleinanlegern und beim
weltbekannten finanzskandal der firma
stratton und von denen der film wird
auch der wall street handelt ding ist im
vergleich dazu wirklich nur absolute
peanuts die es der ex deutsche bank chef
hilmar kopper ausdrücken würde nämlich
um einen läppischen schaden von gerade
mal 200 millionen dollar wenn also eine
so lächerliche summe gut genug war damit
quasi sie daraus einen film mit leonardo
dicaprio dreht das könnte dann hollywood
aus der wak story machen
und ich weiß was du jetzt denkst bei
wirecard ging es zwar um viel mehr geld
als bei wulff der austria aber der
castor ii vielen bestimmt jene frivolen
exzess oder geldgeilen protagonisten mit
partys noten drogen und all dem was eine
ordentliche sex and crime geschichte
ausmacht welche die leute im kino
gesehen worden aber weit gefehlt
wirecard hat all das und noch viel viel
mehr zu bieten es ist ein thriller
voller verdorbenheit moralische abgründe
und sogar spannender geheimdienst
abenteuer aller james bond also das ist
gut auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der gigantische wahlbetrug spielte sich
zum staunen alle über einen durchaus
längeren zeitraum ab und dieser ganzen
zeit drücken die deutschen behörden
nicht nur einen oder gar beide augen
ganz fest zu
sie gingen sogar soweit jene
journalisten der financial times zu
denunzieren welche diesen betrug
investigativ aufzudecken versuchten der
vorwurf gegen sie lautete oz und
marktmanipulation und dieser vorwurf ist
ganz und gar kein pappenstiel im
gegensatz zur übrigen presse ist die
wirtschaftspresse nämlich viel stärkerer
regulierung unterbrochen denn wenn 1
finanzjournalist falsche informationen
über ein unternehmen veröffentlicht kann
dessen börsenwert auf grund dessen
sinken oder steigen und deshalb gibt es
gesetze die so etwas verhindern sollen
aber manchmal können diese gesetze dazu
führen dass eben die vollkommen falschen
personen strafrechtlich verfolgt werden
tja und dieses manchmal es ausgerechnet
der größte finanzskandal der deutschen
börsengeschichte
so ein zufall aber auch in diesem video
geht es darum zu klären was ist der
preis der totalen wahrheit wir werden
diese frage beantworten indem wir uns
genau ansehen was eigentlich der wahre
wirecard skandal ist was hat sich der
staat zu schulden kommen lassen ist es
noch möglich derartigen institutionen zu
vertrauen und wie können diese dinge in
zukunft verhindert werden heute werden
wir diese fragen beantworten aber lasst
uns zunächst einen kleinen blick in die
geschichte werfen
die große europäische hoffnung stell dir
vor du würdest einen online shop mit
hawaii hemden betreiben dort kaufe ich
ein hemd für zehn euro das bedeutet dass
am ende der transaktion auf meinem
bankkonto zehn euro weniger und aus
deinem zehn euro mehr sein müssen ist
eigentlich ganz klar geld die frage ist
nun wer überprüft das sowohl deine bank
als auch meine bank diese überweisung
vollzogen haben höchstwahrscheinlich
hast du eine andere bank als ich vor
allem wenn sie uns in verschiedenen
ländern befinden und diese banken müssen
sich irgendwie miteinander unterhalten
zum beispiel darüber ob auf meinen
kunden überhaupt noch genügend guthaben
vorhanden ist nur gibt es aber tausende
und abertausende von banken auf der welt
und wenn jede mit jeder anderen auf
eigene faust eine verbindung aus handel
und aufbauen müsste würde dies zu einem
unvorstellbare und aufwand spüren und
genau hier kommen elektronische
zahlungs- dienstleister spiel
zum einen gibt es da zum beispiel die
betreiber der zahlungskarten wie
mastercard und visa
dies sehen die bekannten marken dahinter
verbergen sich jedoch oft die betreiber
der technischen infrastruktur und eier
card ist eine solche plattform die
produkte dieser firma ermöglichen es
jedem online händler fast alle möglichen
zahlungsmethoden der welt zu akzeptieren
egal ob man mit dieser mastercard oder
einem anderen system bezahlen möchte
wirecard macht dies möglich
sie zahlen ohne schlange zu stehen
verbraucher können mehrere produkte aus
verschiedenen geschäften in ihren
einkaufswagen legen und mit ihrem
smartphone in einer transaktion bezahlt
sind sie bereits für die zukunft des
bezahlens bayer grad wurde 1999
gegründet und wie so viele andere
internetunternehmen aus dieser zeit ist
auch wirecard damals fast wieder
verschwunden als die dotcom blase
platzte
ich weiß nicht ob sich noch viele von
euch an den großen dot com crash
erinnern können aber während die korona
krise für internetunternehmen den
totalen boom das endgültige erlangen der
weltherrschaft darstellte weil die krise
des jahres 2000 das gegenteil
und genau in jenem moment als wirecard
weniger wert war als eine rolle
toilettenpapier während der virus
hysterie erschien der anti held unserer
geschichte markus traum
mal ganz abgesehen davon dass er wieder
zwillingsbruder des fiesen bösewicht aus
robocop aussieht hatte markus braun
damals eine großartige idee um das am
boden liegende wirecard damals wie ein
phönix aus der asche auferstehen zu
lassen porno websites und online casinos
vielleicht macht mich das überraschen
aber diese unternehmen sind in der regel
vom rest des marktes isoliert viele
zahlungsdienstleister weigerten sich
damals mit der pop branche
zusammenzuarbeiten aber von irgendwas
aus lust und liebe müssen diese website
hier auch leben und dazu eben
überweisungen verarbeiten sehr viel
überweisen und so wurde bayer coach zum
einzigen zahlungsdienstleister weil sie
wie erwachsene unterhaltung nicht
diskriminiert markus braun kaufte damals
ein ruiniertes unternehmen dass er
binnen fünf jahren an die deutsche börse
brachte doch schon damals vermied er den
gründlichen prüfungsprozess der baldigen
börsengang vorgeschrieben ist wie nun
weiter card kaufte eine andere firma die
bereits börsennotiert war allerdings
vollkommen wertlos war sie eine firma
mandelbrot über diesen kam sie dann an
die börse pfiffige kerzen nicht wahr
mit der börsennotierung war dann auch
der nächste schritt möglich eine
schnelle finanzierung mit der die
internationale expansion vorangetrieben
werden konnte und nun möchte ich dass du
dir eine bestimmte zahl merkst zu diesem
zeitpunkt lag der aktienkurs von
wirecard bei die märkte diese zahl denn
sie ist wichtig für euro pro aktien mit
aller liquidität welche die investoren
bei a car zur verfügung gestellt hatten
hatte ich will man dann den großen
sprung gewagt im jahr 2007 eröffneten
sie ein büro in singapur und stellten
den zweiten anti helden unserer
geschichte ein ego kurniawan den asien
pazifik direktor von bak
schon wieder so ein schwieriger typ aber
diesmal nicht wie ein bösewicht aus dem
klassiker wie robocop sondern eher aus
einem schlechten bini
welche strategie hatte dieser mann in
asien für wirecard zu erobern nun ganz
einfach alles erklären was nicht bei
drei auf den bäumen selbst plötzlich
kaufte der wirecard alle möglichen
kleinen unternehmen auf die online
zahlung in lokalen märkten anboten ein
kleines unternehmen auf den philippinen
ein weiteres in dubai und so weiter und
so fort bis 2014 boot war
dienstleistungen in australien
neuseeland südafrika und der türkei an
zu diesem zeitpunkt war die wirecard
aktie bereits auf 30 euro gestiegen das
heißt in weniger als zehn jahren hatte
sie ihren kurs um das 6 fache gesteigert
auf aktionärsversammlungen ging es zu
wie auf rauschenden sieges feiern jedes
jahr war besser als das vorhergehende
aber täuscht sich nicht schon damals gab
es dinge die nicht ganz zusammen passten
und ein mann begann besonders
misstrauisch zu werden und in der sache
herum zu stochern
denn matt chrom reporter der
pfannenschmidt heißt
wirecard ist eine wenig bekannte
deutsche technologie aktien im wert von
fünf milliarden euro
aber sie gibt rätsel auf denn das
unternehmen wächst mit atemberaubender
geschwindigkeit und kaufte sehr obskure
zahlungs unternehmen auf der ganzen welt
auf um dieses wachstum aufrechterhalten
zu können
dieser artikel stammt aus dem jahre 2015
und im grunde ging ist um eine große
frage wie ist es möglich dass bayer card
ruiniertes firmen in asien aufkauft und
sie in nur einem jahr extrem profitabel
macht die schafft war kataster die man
konnte dieses geheimnis genau erklären
und genau dies hätte eigentlich schon
die aufsichtsbehörden in deutschland
dazu bringen sollen dieses unternehmen
immer etwas genauer unter die lupe zu
nehmen in deutschland heißt die
finanzaufsicht die sich mit diesen
dingen befasst bafin bundesanstalt für
finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht diese hat
er jedoch scheinbar keine große lust von
ihrer aufsichtspflicht im fall wirecard
irgendwie gebrauch zu machen
wirecard war das große deutsche hoffnung
unternehmen vielleicht würde daraus ja
mal sowas wie das europäische facebook
oder google werden zumindest ähnlich
erfolgreich und mächtig jedes land
träumt von einer solchen mega erfolgs
story welche einer volkswirtschaft einen
ordentlichen boost verleihen kann um die
reine vorstellung von den dimensionen zu
geben über die wir sprechen drei 2016
kaufte wirecard die gesamte
prepaid-karten sparte der drittgrößten
amerikanischen band city kurz gesagt
bayer card stürmte durch die ganz große
tür auf den amerikanischen markt in
brasilien gelang ihnen im gleichen jahr
etwas ähnliches und zu diesem zeitpunkt
war die aktien bereits mehr als 40 euro
wert ja und im jahr 2017 veröffentlichte
das deutsche manager magazin den folgen
artikeln
das 250 millionen euro rätsel des börsen
wunder dass wirecard manager magazin.de
hat in der bilanz des gefeierten tec dax
riesen wirecard eine ebenso große wie
ominöse forderungs position entdeckt
alles markt bekannt wiegelt der
milliardenschwere zahlungsdienstleister
ab aber das stimmt so nicht
[Musik]
nun war tat versucht das rätsel wie
folgt zu erklären man kaufe zahlungs
unternehmen in asien die praktisch
unbekannt und sehr wenig wert sein da
nutzen man deren kundenstamm
strukturiere der firmen um indiziere
ihnen eine menge überlegene wire card
technologie und geschäftsprozesse und
schaffe so innerhalb eines jahres den
turnaround die verlustbringer werfen
christliche sattel gewinn ab
in nur fünf jahren verdreifachte seinen
gewinn tatsächlich war der
zahlungsdienstleister im januar 2009 10
bereits mehr wert als die deutsche bank
sein börsenwert lag also bereits über
den der größten bank deutschlands damals
schaffte bayer kann sogar den aufstieg
in den deutschen börsen olymp den
deutschen aktienindex dax der 30 größten
börsennotierten unternehmen umfasst das
war sozusagen der ritterschlag die
adelung einer firma die aus dem
dunstkreis von parkour seiten und
online-casinos empor gestiegen war
mittlerweile zählten zu ihren kunden
mehr als 100 fluggesellschaften und
große supermarktketten wie aldi der
aktienkurs stieg auf schwindelerregende
190 euro
[Musik]
24 milliarden euro marktkapitalisierung
gut im vergleich zu billion unternehmen
wie apple amazon facebook oder microsoft
ist das natürlich ein pappenstiel aber
für europäische und deutsche
verhältnisse ist dies gigantisch die 15
jahren war eine aktie von 5 auf 190 euro
gestiegen die anleger feierten die firma
wie einen messias ja aber just zu diesem
zeitpunkt als die begeisterung am
größten war begann die wirecard aktie
zum ersten mal zu fall und du fragst
dich warum ausgerechnet zu diesem
zeitpunkt das ist mal gut auf die gegen
den strom schwimmen was würdest du davon
halten wenn ich dir sagen würde dass du
viel geld damit verdienen kannst dass
eine aktie fällt für manche klingt das
vielleicht ein wenig unlogisch wenn die
meisten leute gehen doch davon aus dass
man eine aktie dann kauft man denkt sie
würde in zukunft steigen nun es gibt
aber auch eine andere technik den
sogenannten leerverkauf und der
funktioniert so stell dir vor es ist
august 2008 10 du hast 1000 bayer aktien
in einem depot und alles scheint wunder
prächtig zu laufen der kurs liegt bei
190 euro aber du glaubst das sei erst
der anfang dieser erfolgsstory
schließlich wovon analysten kursziele
von 250 oder 300 euro auf du denkst also
du müsstest einfach nur noch ein oder
zwei jahre warten dann könntest du noch
im all rund 100.000 euro oder noch mehr
verdienen
tja und zu diesem zeitpunkt komme ich
und unterbreitete ein noch besseres
angebot wie wärs wenn du mit deinem
wirecard-aktien für ein jahr aus leisten
natürlich gegen einen guten ordentlichen
ca
nachdem das nicht toll den zweier haben
bekommst du deine wirecard aktien plus
zinsen zurück und kannst du dann zu dem
von der ersehnten kurs verkaufen also
noch mehr reibach machen und du sagst ok
großartig ich hatte eh nicht vor diese
aktien zu verkaufen um das extrageld
auslösen kann ich gut gebrauchen
die also leistest du mir deine 1000 neue
karte aktien und was mache ich nun ich
bin short verkäufer also verkaufe ich
die aktien sofort zum aktuellen kurs von
190 euro pro stück streiche also 190.000
euro ein
aber was bedeutet dass ich habe dir doch
versprochen die 1.000 aktien wieder nach
zwei jahren also im august 2020
zurückzugeben nun in knapp zwei jahren
also kurz vor der rückgabefrist muss ich
diese 1000 bayer kalt aktien eben wieder
am markt zurückkaufen und sie dann
anschließend zurückgeben plus ein zins
dann ist unser vertrag erfüllt und alles
wird glücklich nun mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht alle denn ich
als shortseller hoffe dass der
aktienkurs von wirecard im august 2020
tiefer liegen wird als die 190 euro für
die ich sie im august 2008 10 verkauft
habe und in diesem fall würde meine
wette aufgehen so und zum zeitpunkt als
wir dieses video drehen dümpelt der kurs
von wirecard bei gerade mal zwei euro
herum das bedeutet ich kann die 1.000
aktien die ich dir schulde für schlappe
2000 euro zurückkaufen und seht ihr
zurückgeben
ich habe bei diesem deal also 188.000
euro abzüglich des kleinen zinses
verdient und das quasi ohne eigenen
kapitaleinsatz aber natürlich hätte das
ganze für mich auch nach hinten losgehen
können wenn der kurs von wirecard bis
zum rückgabe stichtag nicht gefallen
sondern gestiegen wäre sagen darauf jede
300 euro da hätte ich 110.000 euro plus
zinsen verloren und da es für den kurs
einer aktie theoretisch keine obergrenze
gibt kann das verlustrisiko eines short
sellers unglaublich hoch sein
so mancher hat sich damit schon verwoben
wie zum beispiel der milliardär hatte es
merckle dem der größte deutsche
generikahersteller ratiopharm der größte
deutsche pharmahändler phoenix und der
größte deutsche baustoffkonzern
heidelberg cement gehören wie im jahr
2008 tätigt er mit vielen anderen
leerverkäufe und wetterte gegen die
volkswagen-aktien dann jedoch gab
porsche bekannt vw übernehmen zu wollen
der vw kurs stieg und stieg und all die
leerverkäufer wurden immer nervöser
dass sie die aktie bis zur rückgabe
stichtag nicht mehr günstig zurückkaufen
können sie gerät in panik und verkauften
wie verrückt alle am markt verfügbaren
vw-aktien woraufhin der kurs innerhalb
von zwei tagen von 200 auf über 1000
euro in die höhe schoss nicht weil vw
wirklich so viel wert gewesen wäre
sondern weil einfach zu viele short
seller auf einmal ihre kontakte erfüllen
muss zu wenige folgten die aktie
verkaufen und so viele mussten kaufen
eine solche situation nennt man short
squeeze die shortseller werden aus dem
market which und als ein paar tage
später der vw kurs wieder auf 250 euro
gefallen war war es für die
leerverkäufer bereits zu spät der
stichtag war verstrichen und sie hatten
insgesamt über 15 milliarden euro
verloren viele von ihnen ihr gesamtes
vermögen der schwäbische milliardär
merckle beging daraufhin selbstmord
indem er sich von einem zug überrollen
ließ also liebe kinder macht das nicht
zu hause nach mit denen leerverkäufen
denn man muss schon eine gehörige
portion erfahrung und vor allem courage
besitzen um gegen den markt zuwenden
versucht dir mal die situation im januar
2009 10 zu vergegenwärtigen breuer card
hatte eine gewaltige glückssträhne die
bars sind beauftragte einen
dienstleister um die bilanzen des
unternehmens zu prüfen
dieser sagte es solle alles in ordnung
auch das wirtschaftsprüfungsunternehmen
bei einer der big four bescheinigte
wirecard einen reibungslosen
geschäftsbetrieb mit anderen worten alle
quellen mit autorität sagten bayer card
ist die zukunft man musste verrückt sein
um gegen so ein unternehmen leerverkäufe
tätigen oder nur so ist das halt mit
leerverkäufern sie sind sozusagen die
verschwörungstheoretiker der märkte sie
glauben eine andere wahrheit zu kennen
als die offizielle als die des
mainstreams aber mit einem unterschied
in diesem fall hat
wahrheit einem kreis sie riskieren ihr
eigenes gutes geld weil sie wirklich
glauben dass etwas nicht so gut läuft
wie alle anderen denken und nicht nur
dass leerverkäufer haben in der regel
auch einen schlechten ruf da sie ja
davon profitieren dass etwas gehörig
schief geht und all dies erklärt warum
sie im februar 2009 10 eine nachricht
wie diese sehen mussten
[Musik]
marvin verbietet leerverkäufe von
wirecard aktien nach einem crash das ist
richtig die deutschen und finanzbehörden
wollten ihr kleines facebook schützen
sie wollten nicht dass ein paar
leerverkäufer das unternehmen schlecht
machen vielleicht hatten sie angst
andere investoren würden angesichts
sagte leerverkäufe nervös werden und
ihre wahlkarte aktien verkaufen wollen
am ende könnte der wirecard kurs
wirklich sinken aber nein das würde die
bafin ihrem liebling ihrem nationalstolz
wirecard doch nicht antun nein besser
ist es all jene einzelkämpfer die
gegenwart retteten und die whistleblower
die auf die probleme bei wirecard
hinwiesen als alle träger abzustempeln
und so dachten viele anleger die ihr
sauer erspartes an wirecard investiert
hatten natürlich die financial times
würde einfach nur fake news öffentlichen
und wie eingangs erwähnt lernen fake
news in der finanzpresse bestraft
die bundesanstalt für
finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht bafin hat
strafanzeige gegen zwei journalisten der
financial times und mehrere
leerverkäufer wegen möglicher
marktmanipulationen erstattet grund
waren berichte über mutmaßliche
unregelmäßigkeiten in der bilanzierung
bei wirecard und die staatsanwaltschaft
in münchen wo magath seinen sitz hat war
mehr als zuvorkommend und eröffnete ein
strafverfahren gegen die journalisten
genau jeden der das technologie juwel
der deutsche nationen kritisiert wollte
der deutsche staat mit vater
strafverfolgung mundtot machen ich weiß
was du jetzt denkst welche
schamlosigkeit was für ein amts- und
machtmissbrauchs die typisch bayerische
an nico mentalität mit korruption
seilschaften und staatlich gedeckten
betrug zeigt sich wieder in ihrer vollen
pracht stadt die kleinanleger zu
schützen kämpfte der deutsche staat mit
aller härte gegen die einzigen welche
die wahrheit sagt hoya das alles ist
leider wahr
jetzt wo wir das ende dieser geschichte
kennen können wir leicht sagen dass hier
eine gewaltige ungerechtigkeit geschafft
aber leider sagen dass viele im jahr
2019 ganz anders viele menschen wollten
eben nicht wahrhaben dass die welt eine
schlechte ist dass korruption gibt nein
doch nicht im sauberen deutschland und
im piekfeinen münchen oder was hättest
du gedacht wenn man dir gesagt hätte
dass eine zeitung aus dem bösen drexhage
großbritannien fake news über das
deutsche vorzeigeunternehmen wirecard
veröffentlicht und sie sich dafür vor
gericht verantworten müssen
hättest du erkannt dass hier ein
gigantischer betrug vor sich geht oder
hättest du dich lieber wieder schlafen
gelegt mit den beruhigenden gefühl dass
in deutschland dem land der aufrechten
und gerechten dass ich so gerne als
moral weltmeister sieht alles seine
ordnung hat wo wir überlassen dir dies
für dich persönlich zu reflektieren und
daraus auch auf andere vorgänge zu
schließen auf jeden fall hatten die
betrügereien bei wirecard mittlerweile
aber so große ausmaße angenommen dass
selbst alle bemühungen der bafin den
sturz der betrugs firma nicht behindern
konnten und erst haltet euch mal fest
[Musik]
skandal der deutschland erschüttert
oktober 2009 10 der kurs von wirecard
liegt jetzt bei 110 euro aus der
tatsache dass die bach den leerverkäufe
verboten hat veröffentlich die fahne ist
weiterhin analysen die das unternehmen
nicht gut dastehen lassen
die journalisten wollen immer noch nicht
glauben das ist dann asiengeschäft mit
rechten dingen zugeht sie lassen sich
nicht durch die deutschen
strafverfolgungsbehörden einschüchtern
und auch nicht durch die ganzen top
anwälte und privatdetektive die wirecard
angeheuert hat um sie auf schritt und
tritt zu beobachten und fertig zu machen
denn wenn man weiß dass man gegen
schwindler betrüge und scharlatane
kämpft muss man oft einfach nur genügend
durchhaltevermögen beweisen und warten
bis die betrüger mit all ihrer schiffe
und unverfrorenheit einen fatalen fehler
begehen obwohl sie sich vollkommen
sicher sind kein zu begehen und bayer
tat begingen diesen zähler
als es dem markt mit einer weiteren
prüfung durch kpmg zu beruhigen versucht
[Musik]
wirecard beauftragt kpmg mit
unabhängiger prüfung nach vorwürfen der
financial times
ok warum taten sie das nun großer
unternehmen sind verpflichtet ihre
bilanzen von einem
wirtschaftsprüfungsunternehmen
attestieren zu lassen diese
wirtschaftsprüfungsunternehmen werden
auditoren genannt weltweit gibt es vier
große wirtschaftsprüfer die gewöhnlich
big four genannt werden deloitte
pricewaterhousecoopers wie weil young
und kpmg
bisher wurden die bücher von wirecard
durchgeprüft aber da der markt ihre
autos nicht mehr zu 100 prozent traute
sagte wirecard okay wir lassen uns
zusätzlich auf rein freiwilliger basis
nur von einem anderen auditor prüfen
damit sich die investoren beruhigen
können und wahrscheinlich handelt es
sich bei dieser beauftragung von kpmg
auch um einen trick denn immerhin hatte
markus braun der ceo von wirecard die
jahrelang bei kpmg gearbeitet
wahrscheinlich dachte er dass seine
alten freunde und seilschaften bei kpmg
team noch immer wohlgesonnen sein werden
ihnen dabei helfen alles unter den
teppich zu kehren oder zumindest im
entscheidenden augenblick mal in eine
andere richtung gucken deren beyer
carlsen scheingeschäfte maskiert welch
irrtum
wirecard hätte keinen größeren fehler
beginnen können als kpmg zu beauftragen
kpmg bericht verstärkt misstrauen bayer
card was für eine klitsche eine kpmg
sonderprüfung sollte den
zahlungsdienstleister wirecard endlich
von allen vorwürfen rund um bilanz und
governance freisprechen
dieser plan ist auf ganzer linie
gescheitert die wirtschaftsprüfer werfen
mehr fragen auf als sie beantworten und
zeichnen das bild eines unternehmens das
an einer aufklärung nicht sonderlich
interessiert ist
[Musik]
im grunde entdeckten dann sowohl über
als auch kpmg dass wirecard guthaben
über 19 milliarden euro frei erfunden
hatte einfach so der cut lag das geld
auf den philippinen ihren angaben
zufolge nutzten viele kilos die vakanz
zahlungssysteme wie verrückt und
bescherten dem unternehmen dort
gigantische gewinne bislang glaubte
jeder an diese zahlen und wer würde
schon extra auf die philippinen reisen
um dort nachzusehen zumindest war dies
wohl der grundgedanke der wahlkarte
masterminds das ganze pack dessen schön
intransparent weitab von münchen und den
prüfern aufbauen
nur leider entschied sich jemand doch
mal in den angeblichen ballkarten
wohnungs in manila nach zu sehen bei
solch einem milliardengeschäft würde man
ein großes repräsentatives bürogebäude
erwarten oder nun das philippinische
imperium von wirecard verfügte in
wahrheiten über ein kleines büro welches
es sich zudem mit einem busunternehmen
teilte die philippinische zentralbank
selbst behauptete sie keine wahlkarte
überhaupt nicht dabei besteht nach
philippinischen recht eine melde- und
prüfungspflicht wenn ihr vermögen mehr
als fünf prozent der philippinischen
devisenreserven beträgt und mit zwei
milliarden euro hätte sich wirecard für
diese routineinspektion durch die
behörden mehr als qualifizierter cards
niederlassung auf die philippinen weiter
nichts als ein kartenhaus und als dieses
krankenhaus dann einstürzte rollten bei
wirecard die köpfe
[Musik]
polizei-razzia in den wirecard büros in
singapur nach einem bericht in der
zahlungsbilanz des betrugs beschuldigt
wird
[Musik]
ehemalige bayer kasino markus braun nach
zwei milliarden dollar skandal verhaftet
in der zwischenzeit hat wirecard kurs
angemeldet und der anwalt des
unternehmens auf den philippinen
bestreitet jeglichen kontakt mit seinem
mandanten behauptet gar das unternehmen
habe seine unterschriften auf allen
urkunden gefälscht so und wenn du denkst
dass all diese unglaublichen geschichten
rund um wirecard nicht mehr zu toppen
sein halt dich fest denn jetzt stellen
wir dir den mann vor der all das noch
mal getoppt die größte knall schaden von
jan marsalek markus browns rechte hand
und bis vor kurzem noch chief operations
officer von wirecard der österreicher
mit tschechischen namen ist eine der
schillernsten figuren dieses thriller
ohne studium abitur stieg er bereits mit
30 in den weiher card vorstand auf
zuständig für das operative geschäft und
fürs grobe kenner bezeichnen ihn als
nach außen immer höflich kontrolliert
und charmant mit seinem leichten wieder
akzent und nach innen als einen der
abgezockte ssten typen die sie je erlebt
während seiner zeit bei bayer tat soll
er einen dreistelligen millionenbetrag
in die eigene tasche gewirtschaftet also
und wort haben aber marschalek war viel
mehr als ein dieb und
wirtschaftsverbrecher er war fasziniert
von geheimdiensten james bond sein
großes ego während er gegenüber der
öffentlichkeit das image des korrekten
steinigen und weltgewandten dax-vorstand
warte verkehrte er privat in der
halbwelt von geheimen installation
zylinder schmiss exzessive partys auf
denen alles serviert wurde auch mal
sushi auf nackten frauenkörper ihm
werden verbindungen zur russischen
agenten nachgesagt und bei der münchner
staatsanwaltschaft soll er damit
geprahlt haben er betreibe fand
aufklärung und lassen sich von einer
ausländischen regierung mit
informationen versorgen mit denen leute
die sich in den weg stellen
kompromittieren können es wird behauptet
er habe sich informationen des
österreichischen inlandsgeheimdienstes
beschafft und sie an die
rechtspopulistische fpö weitergegeben
aber es wird noch besser er soll sich
sogar die geheime formel des
nervengiftes nur schock geschafft und
pläne geschmiedet haben in libyen eine
eigene bis an die zähne bewaffnete miliz
von 15.000 mann aufzubauen und nein
das alles ist keine verzweifelten bee
movie 3
buchautor auf einem lsd-trip eingefallen
das hat dieser mann tatsächlich in der
realen welt getrieben
das war das leben eines
vorstandsmitglieds eines dax
unternehmens nun mittlerweile wird
wahrscheinlich mit internationalem
haftbefehl gesucht und befindet sich auf
der flucht feststeht war kalt als die
große hoffnung der deutschen technologie
wirtschaft und hat sich nun als
hochgradig kriminelles unternehmen
entpuppt das von der deutschen regierung
jahrelang gedeckt wurde
aber lohnt ist die büchse der pandora
geöffnet ein fass ohne boden aus dem
jeden tag neue hiobsbotschaften über
look betrug und alle arten krimineller
machenschaften hervor sprudeln nichts
scheint unmöglich ausgeschlossen das
us-justizministerium zum beispiel
untersucht eine verwicklung der karte in
einen 100 millionen dollar schweren fall
von bank betrug im zusammenhang mit
einer online handelsplattform für
marihuana für deutschland ist dies alles
ein moralischer super gau die ganze welt
beginnt nun den vermeintlichen sauber
land zu misstrauen kann man als investor
den unternehmen dieses landes noch
vertrauen jetzt wo klar wird dass
deutsche kontrollinstanzen eher daran
interessiert sind kriminelle
machenschaften zu vertuschen
als sie aufzudecken welche weiteren
faulen dinge gehen in deutschland vor
sich wandelt lasst den nächste wochen
bei der anleger um milliarden betrogen
werden gegenwärtig werden bereits namen
von bafin und genoss die direkt in
diesen skandal verwickelt sein könnten
allein die tatsache dass ein unternehmen
zwei milliarden euro
sicherheitsleistungen 25 prozent seiner
bilanzsumme in einem land wie den
philippinen parkt hätte alle
alarmglocken schrillen lassen müssen und
in diesem fall geht es nicht nur darum
dass die behörden nicht in der lage
waren ein betrug aufzudecken sie haben
sich aktiv dafür eingesetzt als jede zum
schweigen zu bringen die auf den betrug
hingewiesen haben sie missbrauchten das
um ihre autorität und macht die inform
souverän also verfolgt übertragen wurde
um gegen unterhalten fake news zu
kämpfen
stattdessen jedoch bekämpfen sie die
wahrheit brandmarkten sie als
verschwörungstheorie und stellten ihre
verbreitung unter strafe und hört dieser
skandal überhaupt bei der finanzaufsicht
und der staatsanwaltschaft münchen auf
handelt es sich nicht um ein
systematisches problem eine toxische
obrigkeit mentalität die sich in
deutschland auf allen ebenen der
staatsgewalt und elitär medialer
machtstruktur ausgebreitet hat und sich
mit zunehmender geschwindigkeit weiter
aus
weiter führt die hexenjagd gegen echte
oder vermeintliche fans nicht auch an
vielen anderen stellen so fatalen
exzessen und machtmissbrauch zu einer
ernsten gefahr für demokratie aufklärung
und meinungsfreiheit zumindest im fall
wirecard ist diesen offenbar geworden
doch was wenn es sich wie in den meisten
solcher fälle um die spitze des eisbergs
handelt
fakt ist der staatssekretär im
bundesfinanzministerium jörg hube straff
sich im vergangenen jahr mehrfach mit
wirecard und die bundesregierung weigert
sich nun mit aller macht die inhalte
dieser gespräche offen zu legen sie
beruft sich auf geheimkonten warum aber
müssen gespräche mit einem
zahlungsdienstleister von der regierung
als geheime verschlusssache
klassifiziert werden sind da wirklich
nationale sicherheitsinteressen spiel
oder doch eher möbel und politische
partikularinteressen was glaubst du wie
weit dieser skandal gehen hätte ja
irgendwie vermieden werden können wie
sollte man die regierung mit all ihren
kontrolleuren und sensoren kontrollieren
damit diese ihre macht nicht
missbrauchen
wie weit kann uns diese geschichte dazu
bringen die debatte und fake news aus
einem anderen blickwinkel zu betrachten
ich persönlich denke dass es sehr viele
fake news gibt und man ganz bestimmt
lernen muss mit diesen umzugehen aber
eine starke demokratische gesellschaft
darf sich nicht aus jeder kleinen
verschwörungstheorie selbst einen strick
drehen ich denke diese geschichte zwingt
uns dazu viele dinge diesbezüglich zu
überdenken schreib uns deine meinung
darüber bitte als kommentar unter dieses
video teil dieses video bitte auch mit
deinen freunden und wenn du die
kommenden videos nicht verpassen
möchtest drücke bitte auch auf den abo
knopf und aufs knöpfchen um keines
unserer updates zu verpassen
falls ihr denkt dass euch dieses video
etwas gebracht hat geht uns bitte auch
leid und macht gut bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]